hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the world Fisher random
Championship it is Yani Pony versus
Magnus Hoth and this is the first game
do we are going to cover this is their
first uh round game and even though we
will not be having a classical World
Chess Championship between nepo and the
Magnus they still face each other in
another world championship that is the
official random World Championship it's
quite a game really brutal it has a
really Wild start you guys will enjoy it
let's check it out uh Nepal with the
white pieces opens with Ponte F4 and it
makes sense the rook and queen are
nicely placed on the FNG file so you
might as well start pushing that FNG
Pawn open up the light Square bishop and
enjoy a nice game we have Pawn to F5 and
now G4 right away by nepo ah sorry about
that
uh we have G6 by Magnus opening up his
dark Square bishop and now Knight a to
B3 we have F characters on G4 Queen
captures and now Knight 8 to B6 we have
Knights the C5 and now we have Knight to
D6 uh you can't really uh move the D
Pawn if you move the Deep on then you
allow Knight stays check and that's
gonna be deadly
uh so Knights the D6 we have Knight one
the B3 and now Knight B to C4 uh
improving the position of the Knight we
have Pawn to C3 and now Pawn to A5 and
grabbing more space on the queen side uh
also you might have some ideas of this
lodging the Knight with Pawn to A4 so
Knights the D4 right away and the Magnus
grabs it right away uh because uh the E6
square is now targeted by both Knights
and if you play a weird move then a nice
night C to E6 check and that's just game
you have to go under the mask of the
queen and then you just gobble up The
Rook for three Knight captures opens up
a discovery and black resigns so Magnus
gets rid of the Knight Bishop captures
on D4 C characters and now Pawn to B6
says uh you know move your Knights
somewhere somewhere else night the D3
and now Pawn to G5 by Magnus uh putting
pressure on that um uh Pawn here and you
don't really have the luxury of
capturing as the rook and F1 would hang
so Pawn to B3 chases the Knight away
Knight to A3 attacks the rook and Rook
the C1 and here Magnus plays the the
sneakiest of moves Bishop to F7 and it
seems like a normal developing idea uh
you don't really believe that there's
anything
um a vial happening here so Jan does the
same he plays Bishop to F2 but he misses
uh a beautiful move by Magnus so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the winning idea for Magnus already
on move 13 while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
muttered mate and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is best
of characters and B3 and of course it is
the first move that comes to mind but
you have to spot the second move of the
line and that's uh where the beauty of
the uh of the combination lies eight
characters on B3 and now not Queen
captures on B3 if you play Queen
characters on B3 first then King to E1
and the Knights the C to check while it
looks very scary you can simply capture
The Rook captures on C2 and now there is
no Checkmate because there is a knight
uh covering the C1 Square so you can
push the Rook back to C1 and capturing
on C2 is is okay with just Bishop D3 you
free up the F2 Square for the white king
and everything is perfectly fine however
Magnus spots the other a very important
move and that is Rook captures on F4 now
the queen is hanging and of course the
Knight can never move from D3 uh because
of the smothered mate if the Knight
captures then Queen captures on B3 now
you don't have this because then you
just get it checkmated so you have to
play King the E1 and not Knight the C to
check again you cannot capture Queen to
B1 will result in Checkmate so King to
D1 and now of course the smartered mate
uh happens Knight the E3 a double uh
check from the queen and the Knight King
the E1 and the spectacular Queen to D1
with check I know most of you guys know
this but some of you may not uh know
what a smarter mate is or may not have
seen it in a long time so just captures
ignite the seed to a beautiful beautiful
uh Checkmate that's okay after Bishop
captures on B3 uh we said a characters
root captures an F4 and not nipple plays
Queen to H5 so The Rook is uh not up for
grabs Queen capture some B3 check King
the E1 and not Knight the C2 check Rook
captures now you have to capture Queen
captures on C2 and now Pawn to E3 so
nipple does survive he offers the Knight
for The Rook uh night for the Rook but
Magna just goes back Rook to F6 and now
Knight the e five we have Queen side
Castles by Magnus and now Queen to G4
putting pressure on that D7 Pawn so you
can't just double up on the f file and
so Magnus just plays Pawn to H5 he wants
to get the Queen off of this diagonal uh
Queen back to D1 offering a queen crate
and now just Queen to A2 we have Queen
to C1 and now Rook Dita f8 putting
pressure on that f file Bush up to G2
and now we have Pawn to A4 Magnus just
starts advancing his pass Pawn uh we
have King the E2 and now Queen to B3
moving the queen away from the a file so
you can continue pushing the pawn Knight
to D3 and now uh not the a83 right away
then Queen to C3 might be a bit annoying
uh first queen to B5 just prevent that
knight from moving and now Rook captures
on F2 is such a such a such an ugly
threat uh we have Queen to C3 now comes
H4 uh and now we have Rook the C1 very
interestingly nepo even allows The Rook
captures an F2 for some pressure against
the the C7 pawn and the while is
perfectly fine to capture on F2 Magnus
doesn't
probably because after Rook captures on
F2 of course the Knight cannot move you
have to move the king now you have to
play 98 to prevent Checkmate and now
after Knight captures on F2 you have to
play Queen F5 now threat and queen
captures Knight and once the Knight
moves you play H3 and here okay white
just resigns because once the bishop
moves if you move it away from the
control of the F1 squared then this is
just Checkmate if you capture then Queen
captures there's no no good
move for you here but Magnus misses this
idea he plays C6 first and okay his
position is still winning and now comes
King to E1 Nippon pins but still Rook
captures an F2 by Magnus and now it's
not as clean as it was before here you
have to start with H3 interestingly and
now again it doesn't matter the bishop
captures on H3 you just play Knight to
the E4 attack the queen attack the
bishop so many times and that's just it
you you can even offer a queen trade you
don't care captures captures and then B5
the pawns are Marching forward that's
too much pressure for you to handle once
the rule goes back you're gonna capture
an F2 and that's it Rook captures Rook
captures and you have well you have the
exchange you have two connected past
pawns here marching forward this is
instant resigns and if H3 if you don't
go back to H1 you could also Play Bishop
captures on H3 uh make uh makes even
more senses oh no a bishop captures on
H3 is what we've covered but in Bishop
H1 not allowing Knight's day for then
you no longer have control over the F1
square and then just root captures on F2
Knight captures uh and now Queen to F5
is again deadly because uh well just
Queen captures an F2 or if the Knight
moves uh Queen to F1 Checkmate the
bishop now has no control over the F1
Square
uh so here H3 was the correct sequence
of moves the Magnus goes for Rook
capture Sun F2 instead and now this
gives Yan a bit more uh space to defend
Knight captures and F2 we have Queen to
F5 and now as uh you haven't uh chased
the the bishop away with H3 just Knight
the H3 and now this is perfectly fine
you do not have the luxury of G4 because
just Knight F4 and now you close the
file completely so here after Knight to
H3 Magnus tries King to d8 Queen to G4
is still winning but uh it's such a
weird move to find King 38 was played
and now comes Queen the B4 Bion going
after the B6 pawn queen to G for now by
Magnus and now Queen captures and B6
check King the E8 with Bishop to F1 and
now of course you will give up The Rook
for two pieces Magnus grabs on F1 King
captures Queen captures on H3 King to G1
and now Queen to G4 check King H1 and
now how do you continue this attack it
seems like that you are very close but
you also have to be very very careful if
you try something like Pont H1 there's a
nice Queen to B8 check and after King to
F7 Rook to F1 check and the once the
king moves uh well something let's say
King here you can go Queen to f8 with
chicken once uh well now it's just
either a draw by repetition or if black
messes up Magnus can even get checkmated
here
so it's uh not a move you want to try a
move you want to try is uh well just
trying to get the king or a F7 right
away without uh moving the Knight but
Magnus goes Knight to E4 and now it
seems like he's threatening mate in one
and it doesn't just seem so it he really
is threatening mate in one with Knight
to F2 check but now Jan just defends
very well Queen B tracking F7 Rook to F1
check Knight the F6 now uh and if you if
you want to stop any repetitional moves
and now we have Queen all the way back
to B1 we have H3 now again threatening
Checkmate in The Rook to F2 very
important you can't play Rook to G1
because of Queen F3 check so Rook to F2
and now Pawn to A3 Magnus continues
pushing on the queen side we have Queen
to F5 offering a queen trade and Magnus
of course declines Queen to H5 Rook to
F1 and now Ponte D5 we have D3 now and
queen the E2 putting pressure on the the
D3 Pawn the works so the queen really
has to be careful here Queen to H7 check
as the Knight cannot move King E6 Queen
Tab 5 check King D6 Queen E5 check King
D7 Queen to F5 check and not finally
King to d8 Magnus manages to hide his
King and now Queen characters on H3 so
getting rid of that nasty Pawn but not
Magnus advances the pawn to A2 you could
also consider capturing a D3 first
Magnus decides to push on A2 first we
have Queen to G2 and now he plays Queen
characters and D3 so this is still not
uh possible because the Rook on F1 would
hang so Rook to A1 and now Queen the B1
with check by Magnus Queen to G1 this is
the only way to defend Queen to beat you
and now Queen to C1 uh Magnus does
straight here Queen captures Rook
captures and not Knight the E4 and with
the C3 Square available to the Black
Knight you will be saving your past a
pawn so Rook the A1 and not Knight to C3
we get is very very complicated end game
where even a slight inaccuracy will cost
uh well in any player of the game but as
Jan is the one defending here most
likely he's the one that will have to be
very very careful King to G2 you have to
bring your strongest piece into the game
that is the king of course with C5 King
to F2 and now Pawn to E5 captures on E5
King to E7 and now King to E1 we have
King to E6 King to D2 and now Pawn to D4
captures captures and now King the C2
the king makes his way all the way to
the queen side King captures on E5 and
now Rook to G1 by on going after the G5
Pawn with check and this is actually a
mistake because now mag if Magnus finds
G4 it's all over you can't capture on G4
because of A1 and if you go King to B2
to cover it then King to F4 and you want
a very very important Tempo but Magnus
misses this he plays King to F4 first
and now Jan can still hold this because
he has H3 available and he does play it
now Magnus does not have G4 and here we
have Knight to E4
activating the Knight again and now the
only way to draw this game for nepo is
to play King to D3 put pressure on the
D4 Pawn with control over D1 square and
that's just it for example if Knight to
F2 check you can capture on D4 if Knight
captures here you just go after the pawn
and now after G4 Rook characters on A2
G3 you don't really care just Rook the
G2 and after a king here you just give
up the rook and it's a draw by
insufficient material so after Knight E4
nipple does not find King to D3 as they
were both a very very long time he plays
Rook the G4 with check but now King the
E3 we have King the B2 Pawn to D3 and
now King captures on A2 and look at this
look at what nepo missed Ponte D2 Rook
the G1 and the D1 Queen absolutely
spectacular by Magnus uh and he was in
this position on a move 67 that
ianiponishu resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here of
course if the queen is captured Knight
the C3 check follow follows with a nice
Fork here and after well you play
anything doesn't really matter that
captures on D1 you're up at night you're
gonna win the pawn uh Queen the beat
Queen the G pawn and of course
completely winning so brilliant stuff
Magnus completely outplayed him already
a winning position on move 13 like we
said brilliant stuff with Bishop
captures on B3 sporting the smothered
mate but it took it took a whole lot to
take down Yan even from that completely
lost position because that's just how
strong Yan is uh so yeah had he found
the the the the correct Square for his
King in the end game here uh King to D3
move then he would get a nice draw but
after Rook to G4 check there's no way
out he missed this uh wonderful Fork
after Magnus brings out the queen
uh so yeah a brilliant uh start by
Magnus uh in the semi-finals of the
Fisher random world championship against
Danny punish you will see what happens
in the other round and we're also going
to cover most likely what happened uh in
the game Hikaru versus I'm not going to
spoil that in case some of you don't
know but it was also quite a wild one uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Johanna
Nathan Halsey Jacoby more chess 960 and
goncalo morovo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event until it finishes thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day